BUT I DON’T WANNA SHOOT ANOTHER DNEWS EPISODE!
Unsurprisingly, emotions are difficult to
pin down.
Even the definition is a little nebulous,
"a natural instinctive state of mind deriving
from one's circumstances, mood, or relationships
with others."
Circumstances OR mood OR relationships that's
pretty much everything we ever do.
Emotions are a visceral state of mind that
hits hard and fast; and is something philosophers
and scientists have struggled with explaining
for millennia.
Emotions start in the brain, so if we want
emotional maturity, what about brain maturity?
According to neuroscience, the brain reaches
full maturity around 25 -- though it varies
from person to person.
The last to mature is the prefrontal cortex,
the area associated with executive functions:
i.e. risk assessment, forward thinking, goal-setting,
evaluations, and emotional regulation!
Ideally, by 25 we understand our place and
ourselves, which explains why teenage emotions
seem to run so much hotter than adult's.
Emotional development comes in two groups,
basic emotion and higher emotion.
The basics are inborn, universal and were
defined by anthropologist Paul Eckman in the
1970s: joy, sadness, anger, fear, surprise,
and disgust.
Babies, adults, everyone experiences these
emotions
If I do this… you know I’m disgusted,
right?
It’s the same thing for everybody.
Higher emotions like jealousy, envy, guilt,
shame, pride and embarrassment come later,
once the brain learns self-awareness and self-consciousness;
but the problem is, emotions aren't easy to
quantify!
Just because we don't understand them doesn't
mean we don't experience them, right?
And that was shown in a hilariously cute study
done by Brigham Young this month.
They looked at children six and under competing
in a block-building contest.
The winners and losers were rigged, so they
could test their emotional responses!
Losers shrugged it off and moved on right
away, but winners stood, hands on their hips,
chest out, and had "obvious swagger!"
The brain of a two year old is not self-aware,
or self-conscious, so they shouldn't understand
pride, but there they were, swagging it up.
When asked about their feelings later, younger
kids who were shown pictures of people expressing
pride would identify it in others if they
were four or older; but not in themselves.
Five-year-olds could see it in themselves
and others; indicating we develop our emotions
as we age.
So, if someone slaps you in the face violently
and unexpectedly, you turn red, feel angry
and have an indescribable urge to lash out;
but if you're younger, that emotion can override
your rational decision-making and cause you
to do something you might later regret, right?
Not always.
Studies from the University of California
Santa Barbara found inducing anger in participants
helped them be more analytical!
Their findings unexpectedly found that even
usually irrational thinkers became careful
thinkers when angry; suggesting that anger
isn't only a physical fight-or-flight response,
but can also focus the mind for decisionmaking.
This is the problem we have when studying
our emotions.
They're so fleeting and deep-seated they're
difficult to measure.
But, according to an essay from the University
of California, Berkeley, emotions help organize
our thoughts and keep our perceptions on track
and motivate social interaction.
So the more emotional maturity we have, the
better we can learn from our emotional responses.
A scientist from the London School of Hygiene
and Tropical Medicine describes disgust as
affecting, "who we’re going to kiss, who
we’re going to mate with, who we’re going
to sit next to… who we're going to shun,"
but disgust is one of the least understood
emotions, because it's not as flashy as the
other basics: sadness, anger, or fear.
Which brings us to another problem with understanding
emotions: there are definitely not just six!
Since the definition of the basic emotions,
scientists have argued there are WAY more
or WAY less; and some have objected to categorizing
emotion altogether!
There's a lot of strong feelings on the study
of emotion, unsurprisingly.
Sociologists, psychologists, neurologists,
biologists, all have a great need to understand
these physio-psychological reactions that
hold sway over our lives; but sadly, they
suck at it.
It's a massive blind spot in science.
We can watch blood flow in your brain with
an fMRI, we can scan brainwaves with EEGs,
measure hormones, blood pressure, skin response,
facial expressions, and many other physical
reactions to the emotion, but we can't objectively
measure the emotion itself.
Evolutionary psychologists theorize emotions,
particularly the outward expressions of them,
were a way for ancient man to signal to our
social group.
Disgust, joy and anger all have universal
nonverbal cues which tell other social members
what's up with us, which may explain why they've
evolved!
Emotions can save lives and facilitate social
bonding, but even still, there's a lot more
work to do, and we didn't even touch love.
Nope.
Too much for just one DNews.
Want to know more?
Ask some questions in the comments and maybe
we'll make another emotional DNews.